thanks trade oh and now it's time to
install the sunshine app on our phones
so to get started let's grab a USB cable
well plug in our device and then we'll
need to enable USB debugging this can be
found in developer options in the
Settings app but note that on Android
devices 4.2 and above the option is
actually hidden by default to find the
secret menu go to the Settings app
scroll down to about phone then go down
to build number and tap on that seven
times then when you go back to settings
you'll see the developer options menu
appear also set up your computer to
detect your device check the instructor
notes for more details we're going to
continue using a device because it's
faster and smoother for development but
if you don't have one that's ok you can
continue using an emulator that we
created previously